foreign
Park
pay attention just for a second
[Applause]
work I think I'm ready for Duty do you
feel ready I think Stanley is a kid
missing
what's the call
to report a bank robbery is this crime
currently in progress today
you see that guy on the bench do you
have a lighter that goes up to something
very hot today
it's like a furnace
it's
like a furnace
there's a safe deposit box
[Music]
but I'm the wrong man
all right
where is she
I know you called the tip in on the bank
heist who the hell are you what makes
total strangers pull off an elaborate
bank heist are you familiar with the
concept of hypnotics hypnotics
hypnotics have the ability to influence
the brain sound
voice good light blocking eyes
have not excused them to make you see a
version of the world that doesn't exist
thanks
saw him anymore next stop
I have to know everything
why me why my daughter
who you're dealing with
what you see isn't real
goodbye
hypnotics makes everything that you see
and do
perfectly normal
foreign